because instagram is is coming for you
like they are they're coming for youtube
they have
they just came for um tick tock um
instagram put vine out of business like
they they come for platforms
hard and man their timing is impeccable
you know they're like
let's wait till president trump starts
talking about doing away with tic tac
boom
here's reals
welcome to the think marketing podcast
the number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm sean cannell
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening
welcome this show is dedicated to
helping you learn how to get your
content noticed
and the latest money making strategies
working right now
online so whether you want to grow your
youtube channel
or you want to maximize video across all
of social media
this podcast is for you hey podcast
listener today's episode is brought to
you by
best igtips.com this is a free resource
that our special guest chalene johnson
has put together for you
teaching you the nine simple steps to
instagram
growth i'll leave the details in the
show notes below and i'll tell you more
about it towards the end of today's
episode which i
am fired up for because shawn and
chalene
really get into the idea that with
everything happening in the world right
now
how do you pivot and build an online
influence like if you're not there yet
how do you get started and why should
you choose instagram as one of your main
platforms to be
driving leads and sales from as a
business owner we know that instagram's
important but
how do you do it and what mistakes are
you making that might be
hurting your instagram growth results
shawn and chalene get into all that and
more on today's episode
welcome back to the think marketing
podcast sean cannell here and i'm so
fired up because today i
have chalene johnson with me and she's
going to be sharing how we can leverage
instagram to grow our businesses reach
more people
and really how to pivot our plan right
now and adapt
to these crazy times in the world but if
you're just meeting
chalene she's a world-renowned
motivational speaker more than 30 years
experience as a health expert new york
times best-selling
author top health podcaster with over 20
million downloads of on her show
tens of million people around the world
have been transformed by her fitness
programs
and she and her husband brett have
are the f founders of smart life
movement and they've built and sold
several multi-million dollar lifestyle
companies
and they've helped countless people do
the same but in addition to that chalene
johnson's a personal friend
and business mentor in my life besides
all of her ninja tactics
on marketing instagram video
selling on video she's also an all-time
snowboarder although
slightly at a lower level of skill than
i
am but at least she can keep up um
are we talking about outfits are we
gonna talk outfits
well your outfits are always on the
cutting edge of uh
fashion and style but if we're talking
about carving
okay all right you you do shred
that so do you so do you and thank you
you always bring the playlist you always
have the shred the gnar playlist
which is uh always keeping the vibe
tradition for us
that's right so uh chalene uh so
grateful
that you are on the podcast today and uh
as we kick it off
for those that um uh are kind of just
getting to know you
how do you describe yourself i don't
know
uh how do i describe it it depends on
who asks right
like yesterday we were in a um a used
fitness equipment store and the guy goes
so what do you guys do and i was like oh
we do fitness you know which we really
don't but i was like oh in this
environment
i describe myself as somebody who helps
people
take an idea and turn it into a business
you know and that's
really how people know me through
fitness is because i know how to do that
i did that for myself and
i love doing that and so all the pieces
that fit into that whether it's
podcasting writing books teaching people
talking to strangers studying this stuff
obsessing over this stuff
um that's what i live for i love that
and
right now you have a unique perspective
because you've been in business for so
many years
online and offline you are immersed in
social media not just yourself but also
your team you have research happening
experimentation across multiple
different accounts
before we dive into the nitty gritty of
instagram
what do you think that people need to be
thinking about when it comes to building
a branded business
in light of the lockdown and light of
the pandemic in light of everything
that's happening in the world right now
well a bunch of things uh number one i
think that
we have all learned that certainty is
the only thing
we're uncertain of right like
we just don't know what's going to
happen tomorrow we don't know what
businesses or industries are going to be
impacted by this
so i think the riskiest thing that any
of us can do whether we're in business
or not is have one stream of income i
think multiple streams of income is key
um i don't know necessarily that
everyone needs to pivot but i do think
that there's an
opportunity to see new
um possibilities like there's so many
problems
right like and and because of that that
means there's so many possibilities
because that's what we do as
entrepreneurs is we solve problems and
in the process help of helping other
people
can turn that into profit so number one
is looking at all those uh
problems as as opportunities and number
two is creating multiple streams of
income
which we can do online right and i think
probably
number three is to
get better at what we're already doing
online
like really truly understanding
how it is we can help people and um and
and that people need to make decisions
quickly like
you're a leader you got to help people
make decisions quickly
so powerful and one of your greatest uh
strengths and passions is instagram
you've got a ton of instagram influence
what a lot of people don't know
is you also have multiple feature
accounts so it's not just your own
instagram account but there's branded
accounts and different niches and you've
leveraged those in a lot of creative
ways um and so
instagram's just such a hot platform so
many people of course listening want to
grow their instagram
some may be thinking about starting
their instagram and some may be thinking
what relevancy does instagram have even
to business
so why instagram and why now
um because instagram is is coming for
you like they are they're coming for
youtube they have
they just came for um tick tock um
instagram put vine out of business like
they they come for platforms hard
and man their timing is impeccable you
know they're like
let's wait till president trump starts
talking about doing away with tic tac
boom here's reels you know to replace
what everyone was doing on tick tock i
think that the demographic is so broad
everyone is using it it's it's kind of
the place to be and it's all things it's
a blog
it's a youtube it is a place that now
creators
are being catered to it's a great place
um
to sell it's a great place to basically
showcase your best work
it's it's a magazine it's stories
it's it's live it's freaking everything
and everyone's there so
um you don't have to use all those
features but they're certainly available
that's powerful and what's been changing
on instagram
lately you mentioned reels break down
what that is for those that are maybe
first hearing that term and maybe some
other changes yeah
brand new just just released this week
so depending on when people are
listening to this
um it is really ins it's tick-tock
and it works very much like tick-tock a
little bit of vine in there i see some
vine
um influence some features on reels
that looks very much like features we
had in vine
for those who can remember that the
differences are it's only 15 seconds
at the moment i think it'll i think
it'll be all the things that tick tock
is eventually it's short little clips
people say well what's the difference
between
instagram reels and instagram stories
not
a lot except that um there's more fun
features i don't really understand why
they didn't just
combine the two except that i really
think they were trying to come for
tick-tock in fact what you do to find
the reels feature is you just swipe up
to your stories
and they've changed the formatting a
little bit so now you can just
you can either create a story or you can
create a reel and those reels are 15
seconds and of course as with
all new features and this is like a
bonus tip for everybody as with all new
features with
instagram when they roll out a new
feature they push that new feature so
like if you open up your explore page
today it's
all reels um reels and igtv because
those are the two
features that instagram is really trying
to feature
and focus in and get you to use and
what's your prediction
in terms of how this is going to affect
tick tock i mean i know there's also
what is it triller and there's byte
do you think that instagram will push
all the other players out of the market
or do you think it's still too early to
tell
i think it's early to tell but if you
were to base it on
past experiences i mean stories
basically crushed snapchat um
and you know when first came out
everyone kind of like laughed at
instagram like hahahaha
why are you doing this who cares and now
it's from
based on the research we've done with
over seven thousand of our members
it's where people go first they go to
the stories
especially once you start following
someone that's where we deepen the
relationship
so will reels be here to stay
i don't know but i wouldn't i wouldn't
bet against instagram
you know so i post up my first reels
today and i'll continue playing on it
because i think number one people are
afraid of tick tock
um and i think there is a good chance
that it could get banned who knows
and um and people don't want to go to
another platform like we you know when
we find out there's
a new platform used we're like ugh i
have to learn that too
you know so i think there's a comforter
a comfort level on
instagram and i think it'll do well
that's powerful and that's even
encouraging to me too because yeah when
you think about
movie to another platform it's it's
almost you're you're you're spreading
yourself
thinner even though there's something
new to learn you're building on the
momentum you already have
or you know that instagram's so proven i
mean it's so established
users owned by facebook a friend of mine
actually said that tick tock was suing
instagram which of course they would be
um but like
what are you gonna do i mean number one
it's probably just to kind of stir up
and make some noise but
but when you're instagram aka
facebook you can't mess with them like
that's an unstoppable of course yeah you
really can't
and it's cool because you know it
there's i think the more features
that they add the more they're going to
attract all the different demographics
and you know depending on who you speak
with everyone uses instagram a little
differently
yeah that's powerful what else has
changed on instagram
maybe more from a strategic standpoint
many people are feeling that maybe the
reach they once got with their posts
is not what they got anymore or they've
been doing the same thing
like the definition of insanity doing
the same thing over and over
expecting different results but the
results just aren't coming
what are some of the new things we need
to be paying attention to if we want to
reach people with our posts or
actually get distribution to our current
followers or reach new followers
well i'm glad you said reach um i think
a lot of people look at their
likes and comments and and say my reach
is down and they're really not looking
at the reach
so number one thing i tell people is you
you just you have to be a business or a
creator account period end of subject or
you shouldn't even be listening
um you can you don't see your insights
you have no idea what is working what
isn't working if you're not looking at
your insights
because if you're only looking at likes
and comments you have
no idea how to reach new people and
and if you are reaching people you're
just seeing likes and comments and
that does not tell the whole story i you
know so when i look at my
insights which i just did a couple of
days ago i did an instagram training for
a big group
and you know i looked at the most
popular posts i had this year
in the last 12 months and you know what
the likes are and i'm like wow
you know this must be the most
successful
uh posts that i have and so in your mind
you might think well i need to create
more of that but when i
when i take those insights and i filter
them according to reach
and then i look at the the posts that
have the highest reach it's a completely
different grid
number one and number two is then when i
filter it to see
which which post got me the most either
profile clicks meaning people are going
to go and click on my website
or new follows like that matters a heck
of a lot more
than likes like likes are a stupid
vanity metrics that don't really tell
you
anything um so i think it's really
important that we look at our insights
so you've got to be a creator or a
business account
um i think in terms of new things that
are coming i can just rapid fire these
like igtv has a ton
of new features including converting
alive immediately into an ig tv so your
lives live indefinitely
instead of for just 24 hours um i think
there's some really cool things that
now that there's a clickable link and
that you can put inside your igtv
description
uh hashtags are dominating on igtv
i also think that there's just some
really
interesting changes in terms of the
aesthetic that makes it so much
easier to like be authentic and be real
and not have to overlay curate your
content on
instagram so when you mention be
authentic and be real
how has that shifted because a lot of
times
when we think about a profile post we
may think about
produced images like just kind of quote
cards over stock photography or
overly produced photography um you know
i follow you everywhere and following
your instagram
i'm noticing a lot of carousels
sometimes a one-two
uh kind of photos i seems to be there's
more
um kind of raw funny
produced photography it would feel like
as opposed to
it feels like some hired photographer
followed you around for one day and you
just pull out of that
batch of photos um what is some of your
thinking
in terms of your strategies right now on
instagram in terms of uh
why you're doing what you're doing okay
so great so let me start first with the
carousels
carousels if i have a photo that i was
going to post as opposed to a video it's
always going to be a series
if at all possible because they perform
better because it keeps people on the
platform longer
so instagram is going to favor if you
will
or weight any content that you produce
that keeps people on that particular
post longer
and so just the act of just even swiping
once
is an engagement it counts as an
engagement instagram can see that there
was a swipe so that's an engagement
number one number two
they're on the platform longer because
they had to look at two pictures
and when i say two you could load up to
10 in a carousel
so i'm always gonna put more content in
there sometimes i'm lazy and only put in
two but i try to put in a bunch
um so carousel igtv
and carousels are like you that's all
i'm gonna post
that's all i'm going to try to post
because anything other than that isn't
going to get me the same kind of reach
and i won't be favored by instagram with
regard to your question
in terms of the aesthetic so here you
and i
everybody who's listening follows
someone
or a whole bunch of people who every
single time they post
you know you don't even read it anymore
because it's that same kind of like soft
they're using the same presets right and
it always looks the same
um like everything's like soft maybe or
they
everything's got like a blue tone or a
pink tone or whatever tone and
everything kind of looks the same
and they have a real aesthetic to it
like there's a certain pose
there's a certain you it's an
expectation you just glance at you're
like yeah of course that's so-and-so and
it
always looks the same well that
eventually
turns into white noise and so a lot of
people
have been saying like oh you know the
instagram is shadow banning me or i
can't get traction
and i don't know what i'm doing wrong
well what you're doing wrong is it just
looks the same every day
and none of us have the attention span
that we once did
and while i followed you initially it's
it's not interesting or new anymore it
doesn't stop the scroll
i assume in fact even if the message is
different because the image always looks
the same
and our brains process the image first
so if the image always looks pretty much
the same
then i'm going to assume even though i
shouldn't that the message is going to
be the same so
it just doesn't stop us you know and and
so i think
the the good news there is that you can
break out of that
branded uh you know aesthetic that
you've been so
such a slave to like people are like oh
i've got to do the quote card and then a
black and white photo
and then a video and then a quote card
then a black and white photo and you
know it's just like
it's this tic-tac-toe thing that they're
so obsessed with what their
page looks like that just doesn't feel
real like nobody lives their life like
that nobody is like that we want to know
who you
are are you legit the photos still need
to pop they still need to be captivating
they still need to
they still need to you know be clear
they still have a certain
level that they have to reach but you
can certainly take them with an iphone
where you've cleaned off the lens
and some thought about lighting and
what's in the background etc but they
don't need to be professional photos and
most of all they need to break up the
pattern the more of a pattern you create
the more white noise that develops in
the part of the person who's following
you and and they if they've spent a
couple of days of seeing your post
here's the deal if i see your post a
couple of times and i don't do anything
with it i just look at them like oh yeah
that's that's always what sean posts
and i don't tap it you're going to stop
showing up in my feed
it's like just a couple of days you're
like buried at that point it makes me
think that sometimes people i even wish
i was having their content distributed
to me if i don't seek them out i'm not
seeing it if that engagement's not been
triggered
yeah and you almost have to do that
yourself like i find if
if there's certain people i want to see
on the regular i have to like make sure
i'm finding their stories and engaging
otherwise
they just disappear wow
um very powerful and i want to now
especially for those that say okay
instagram i want to get distribution on
posts
you drop some powerful um wisdom in
there about making sure you have a
business or a creator account so that
you can measure what matters
and not just likes um but actually
profile clicks
or new follows if people are going to
your profile they can go to your website
and if they go to your website they can
engage with you in business
that's super powerful and at the end of
the day here on the think marketing
podcast
you know people want to drive business
results so what do you tell the people
though
that still you know maybe haven't made
the full connection to where
man you know what's the roi of this like
i'm doing other things in my business
i'm trying to juggle social media
um how can i integrate this into my
day-to-day life to grow my business how
much time
should i be spending on instagram and
and why chalene
will this pay off in my business um when
i've got so many different things to do
where else are you going to get
customers for free i mean literally
it's where else can you stand in front
of 200 people
and make a mark like if even if you're
rich you're only seeing
it's only reaching 200 people like
that's 200 it's like standing and giving
a sales presentation or connection and
in front of 200 people and you just you
can't do that anywhere for free so
the return on investment matches the
effort that you put into developing
those relationships it's my full-time
job
literally instagram i think of it as the
it's probably 80 of my day
is engaging and and strategizing and
really figuring out like what's working
and and more importantly
creating those connections so as you
said i have uh my own personal account
but then
in addition to that we manage ten other
feature accounts
totaling close to three million in
followers
and those feature accounts are accounts
that we've created that aren't like
about me the brand
but you know we all follow accounts
where it's like oh
everything in this account is um home
interiors
or beautiful destinations or um
funny memes or boss babe jokes or
whatever it is right so
we we create feature accounts that
our target audience our avatar our lifer
if you will
we know that's the type of content
they're looking for but it's not
personality driven it's like
it's mentality and need driven and the
reason why we grow those accounts is
because they grow faster
they grow quicker they're easier to
manage they're
way easier to find and produce content
for and
we when we need to we use the stories to
drive
sales and traffic back to whatever it is
we're promoting that relates
to the person who would be following
this account anyways so for example
if i we have an account that's called
home workouts for you and that's all
that it is it's just
we feature fitness folks who have
created
home workout routines and so they offer
like
tons of different ideas of things you
can do at home now the person who's
following that account is someone who's
fitness minded
um who's health-minded and who
and we have a lot of fitness folks
fitness professionals who follow that
account fitness professionals
when covert hit they're all scrambling
going like
what do i do now like i don't have my
classes i know my personal training
clients
it was so easy for us to say like hey we
have a course that can
that can help you take everything you're
doing and
turn it into an online virtual
experience for your customers
so we're always thinking about like okay
how what is it that we
how is it we can serve that target
audience not just serving on that up
anything because it's eyeballs but
giving them very targeted content
that's so powerful and um you summed it
up perfectly
where else can you get free customers
and i love
that she talked about not just pushing
content
by creating posts and strategizing but
spending a lot of time engaging
because i mean that's kind of like foot
traffic like what would it be if someone
walks into your
brick and mortar store and you just
ignore them you don't greet them you
don't ask them questions you don't talk
to them you don't connect with them
that actually happens sometimes and
you're like do you even want my business
like you're just sitting at the but but
really on instagram you have the chance
to like
say hey welcome in can i help you is
there any way i could serve you
that's such a great point like that
exact point is something i
would tell everyone to take action on
and immediately
get in the habit of every time you open
up your app don't click on your last
photo to see how many likes you got
because who cares
don't go to your dms go to tap on the
little heart at the bottom of your
screen
and acknowledge each and every new
follow just create a template
you know customize it change it up from
time to time but like just say like hey
this is really me i just want to say
hello and you know i might not catch all
my new followers but i want to introduce
myself and say
um i appreciate you and let me know if
there's a particular type of content
that you
were hoping to see when you decide to
follow me and
every single time i shouldn't say every
time but i mean like my inbox was filled
with people saying
whoa this is so cool thank you is this a
robot like is this a
is this a program or is this you and
it's it's super cool sometimes i'll just
open up my phone say it's me
you know because then people are like oh
she sees me you know and we all want to
be seen we all want to know that
our voice our follow matters and that's
a really simple way to do
it that's amazing and do you leave that
on do you click
the heart you see they followed you do
you leave it as a comment on one of
their most recent photos or do you do
you know
you dm them yep i damn them awesome well
powerful tip chalene
of course we could talk about instagram
for ever
as well as marketing and business and
i'm excited because
you are speaking at our conference grow
with video live that's coming up
soon and you're going to be going deep
into instagram stories as well
and just all of this new these new
platforms
um i am so grateful for all of your
business wisdom
marketing wisdom and that you and your
team are obsessed with staying on the
edge of what's working
now oh it's gonna be fun i'm i cannot
wait until your event is it's gonna be
so much freaking fun
i'm gonna blow people's minds with
hashtags i'm gonna teach people what
they're doing wrong in their bios
i'm gonna teach them how they can start
converting and growing
their reach without having to do things
a lot
without having to spend so much time i
think is what most people are doing
is it feels like okay i just want to
give up because it's not working
and i can show you in a couple of very
simple ways
how to like 50 increase your reach and
start converting people into customers
well i hope that interview with chalene
johnson
brought you encouragement to double down
on your instagram strategy to grow your
business
and your brand using instagram and
if you are an inner circle member here
at think
we have a special gift for you inside of
your membership area we have a
second interview a part two to this
interview with chalene johnson
exclusive for our inner circle members
where shawn and chalene
break down how do you sell on video
chalene johnson has sold
millions of dollars of product by using
video as her strategy and she breaks
down actionable tips
for your first time or your next time
selling with video
as well as mistakes that people make and
how to overcome the fear
and uncomfortability when it comes to
making sales
through video all of that is inside of
the membership area for our inner
circle members and if you would like
more information about how to join
our monthly group coaching here at think
you can find
that information in the show notes below
and this episode
was brought to you by best igtips.com
this
is chalene johnson's free guide and
video tutorial
if you feel like you're kind of stuck in
a rut when it comes to instagram or
you feel like you're lost in an
oversaturated market
if that sounds like you then this guide
and free video tutorial
is for you chalene walks you through the
nine steps for growing on instagram
and how you can get featured because
instagram rewards those
people who are using its newest features
igtv
is one of those features and one of the
tips that chalene shares in there is
how to do simple igtvs using
the instagram stories that you're
already creating she teaches all that
and more inside of this
free downloaded guide and video tutorial
that's waiting for you
at best igtips.com and now it's time for
the review of the day
first thank you so much for the hundreds
of you that have left us comments on
youtube
and reviews over on itunes it means so
much to us
to see that you are loving this podcast
we're pouring our heart and souls into
it
to bring you not only the best content
but the best
interviews so that you can grow your
business online so
just a little call to action for you if
you can rate
review and subscribe to the podcast so
you get notified
when a new episode drops and today's
review comes from
lmvass i get inspired every episode
i recently discovered think media
podcasts and quickly became a fan
shawn and crew discuss a variety of
marketing branding
subjects in a clear and down-to-earth
manner
which is easy to understand no matter
what your experience level is
sean and heather give the impression
they are your business
side hustle's biggest supporter your
business
side hustle's biggest supporter that's
right i can read it
because they are with each episode i
come away with at least
one actionable thing to improve keep up
the great work
well thank you so much for leaving that
review and i want to challenge you
have you left a review yet here on the
podcast i would love
to read your review on the next episode
and now it's time to take action
lean in are you going to apply what you
learned today on this episode
i want to encourage you to punch fear in
the face and just press
record and that means over on instagram
as well
thank you so much for listening and
we'll catch you in the next episode
bye
you